RUSSIAN SOLDIERS HAVE DIED SO
FAR.
JOINING ME NOW HERE IN
WASHINGTON CNN NATIONAL SECURITY
ANALYST PETER BERGEN.
YOU STUDIED BOTH OF THESE
CONFLICTS EXTENSIVELY AND WROTE
AN OP-ED ON CNN.COM.
THERE IT IS NOW.
NUMBER THAT PUTS VLADIMIR PUTIN
AT RISK.
TALK ABOUT START OF THE WAR,
START OF THE RUSSIAN INVASION IN
AFGHANISTAN.
SIMILARITIES.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> THE BIG -- FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN
THE BIG SIMILARITY IS 15,000
RUSSIAN TROOPS MAY HAVE DIED
ACCORDING TO ESTIMATES FROM NATO
OFFICIALS TO CNN.
THE OFFICIAL NUMBERS DURING THE
1980 WAR AGAINST THE SOVIETS IS
15,000 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS DEAD.
SO IN NINE YEARS OF WAR DURING
'80s, 15,000 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
DIED.
IN ONE MONTH, 15,000 RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS DIED.
VLADIMIR PUTIN UNDERSTAND THE
BERLIN WAR FELL WHEN PULLED OUT
OF AFGHANISTAN.
A YOUNG KGB OFFICER.
HE MUST BE KEENLY AWARE THAT
THINGS CAN CHANGE NOT IN HIS
FAVOR IF ENOUGH BODY BAGS START
GOING HOME.
FURTHER BACK IN RUSSIAN HISTORY.
ROMANOVS LOST WORLD WAR ONE AND
THEN EXECUTED.
YOU FAIL IN WARS, COULD BE A BIG
PROBLEM